Diese gnadenlose Gewalt zwischen Hörern einfach. Flotin! Hallo, aufwachen, liebe Hörer! Schass sie schon? Einfach komplett on edge die ganze Zeit. Ich war so gestresst am Anfang. Ich habe 15 Mate getrunken. Und so klang das auch. Mach mal das Fenster zu, die ganzen Gags gehen zum Fenster raus. Mach's kurz zu. Schliess es. Da ist auch kalt drin. Vorsicht, Vorsicht! Vorsicht, die Chalosie, die Chalosie, die Chalosie. Was ist das, wie er sagt? Was? Chalosie. Chalosie ist ein ganz, ganz komischer Ort für ein französisches Wort. Das ist so ein urdeutsches Die Chalosie.alosie? Ich finde, es sieht aus wie so Flanetta.
Das wäre der richtige, finde ich das richtige Wort.
Wenn ich das sehen würde, ich würde sagen, Flanetta.
Es hat so was Flanetta.
So was Flatterndes.
Das Flalas.
Weil das sind diese einzelnen Jalousieteile, die du so drehen kannst.
Las Fladas.
Flaletas.
Das hat so was ganz, was ein Fl-Laut sehe ich da.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe des DPU, das Podcast-U ganz was in Fl laut, sehe ich da. Und damit herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
Ausgabe des dpu, das
Podcast-Uf und Podcast-Projekt.
Cast! Uf!
Oh!
Folge
127.
Mit dabei, Flo und Tim Will und
Steffen Wiese.
Ich freue mich sehr, wieder zusammengekommen zu sein. Und wir haben einige Hörernahmsten bekommen. Du kannst Nina ruhig zurückschreiben. Du musst jetzt nicht nur weiter aufnehmen. Sie schreibt, wann ich morgen kann und wo. Okay, ganz ruhig, ganz ruhig, ganz ruhig. Okay, schreib ihr einfach zurück so, hey, super nett. Nein, nein, Begrüßungen haben wir schon hinter uns. Also wir haben schon hey, hey, was geht, was geht, haben wir alle schon hinter uns. Alles klar, gut. Kein Hey mehr, okay? Also die Synchronphase ist durch. Ja, wir sind synchronisiert, wissen, was wir jeweils machen, welche Sprache wir sprechen, jetzt geht es darum, wo wir uns werden. Alles klar, okay. Dann schreibt doch mal ganz locker sowas wie, hey Nina, deine wunderschönen Brüste spiegeln sich in meinen Augen.
Im Strand?
Am Strand spiegeln sich im Meer.
Weil ich creepy hinter dir stehe.
Spiegeln sich im Meer.
Spiegeln sich im Spiegel?
Lass mich dein Salz in deinen Augen sein.
Lass mich die Feuerqualle an deiner Wade sein.
Lass mich der Seeigel unter deinem Fuß sein.
Denn du bist nicht mit den Schuhen ins Wasser gegangen, die Papa dir extra eingepackt hat. Lass mich der Sand in deinen Schuhen drei Tage, nachdem du am Strand warst, sein. Lass mich dein Sonnenbrand sein. Behandelbar? Lass mich die UV-Strahlen sein, die durch deinen Körper dringen und Schaden hinterlassen. Okay. Lass mich der Krebs sein, der sich durch deine Blut... Sie schreibt HDF, HDL, Sternchen, HDL, unblockiert. Das ist ein grosser Unterschied. Und ich bin blockiert. Scheiße. Schade. Ich finde dieses Konzept Sonnenbrand unfassbar beängstigend, weil du so wenig falsch machst, eigentlich, für so viel Strafe. Du gehst raus. Das ist alles, was du machst. Es ist mega unfair. Es ist unfair uns gegenüber. Unfair. Weil du gehst raus und machst nichts. Weil dieses aktive Auftragen, dieses aktive Ab-, dieses Verhindern von etwas, damit musst du Sonnencreme auftragen, du musst einen Sonnenschirm tragen, du musst diese lächerlichen Schirmhüte tragen. Nein. Lächerlich. Nein, danke. Turban. Ich meine der Turban, die Entschützung des Turbans oder das, was die Saudi-Arabien-Menschen immer so tragen, dieses Ring auf dem Kopf. Das ist doch Quatsch. Und das zeigt sich für mich auch einfach, dass die Natur unfair ist. Ja, genau. Die Sonne ist gnadenlos. Einerseits Vitamin D brauchst du dringend, sonst stirbst du. Gehen die Sonne lange genug, dann stirbst du. Wie lange hat es gedauert, bis der erste Mensch verstanden hat, dass Sonnenbrand was mit der Sonne zu tun hat? Du bist dann einfach so, ich habe jeden Abend, meine Haut schält sich ab, ich habe Schmerzen, ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, dass ich ein zangenbewehrtes Tier in meiner Flugbahn habe. Ich spreche fließend Englisch. Auch ein kleiner, ein kleiner Seitenheber unserer englischen Mitbewohner, die, man sagt ja immer, dass die die Sonnenbrand, den grössten Sonnenbrand haben.
Apropos Seitenheber unserer englischen Zuhörer, für alle, die die zweite Folge der aktuellen Staffel Rick and Morty, Morty, Morty, Morty, yeah, yeah, Rick.
Ja gut, nur weil du einmal ein Kompliment bekommen hast, machst du das jetzt in jeder einzelnen Folge. Ein Kompliment bekommen für meine Morty-Impression.
Für alle, die die zweite Folge gesehen haben und sich gefragt haben, was sollte das denn? Rick ist plötzlich eine Gurke. Wo ist denn da der Gag? Und alle, die die deutsche Synchro gesehen haben, wie Rick ist eine Gurke. Was ist denn da, hat er ein gurkiges Problem? Nein, he is in a pickle. Verstehst du, alle Podcast-Ufohörer sollten aufschreien und und sagen, yes, ich habe es verstanden. Jeder Engländer versteht es. Ja, aber alle Engländer und alle Podcast-Ufo-Hörer. Von daher, Podcast-Ufo bildet. Und zweiter Fakt der Bildung, die ich heute euch auch mal mitgeben möchte, und zwar, es ist seit kurzem möglich, Emojis als URLs zu benutzen. Habe ich gehört, habe ich mitbekommen, ich weiß nicht, ob es stimmt, aber natürlich da meine Investmentstrategie für diese Woche, die Florentin-Will-Investmentstrategie. Holt euch doch einfach mal Domains von allen Emojis, die es gibt. Holt euch mal die Palme, palme.de, palmeemoji.de. Oder Sonne Palme.de. Irgendwann wird Tui oder irgendeiner von diesen bankrotten Reiseveranstaltern zu euch kommen und sagen, Freunde, palme.de hätte ich gerne und dann sagt die, jetzt aber mal, Kollege, jetzt kommen wir, was aus dem Konkursverfahren noch mal übrig bleibt, Kollege. What? Ich glaube, nächste Woche ruft Thuy bei uns an und sagt so, Entschuldigung, wissen Sie mehr als wir? Uns geht es sehr gut, dachten wir bis eben. Was haben Sie für Informationen, die wir nicht haben? Thuy kratzt doch seit Jahren am Bankrott. Wo ist Neckermann? Ja, haben wir aufgekauft. Wo ist der Neckermann? Aufgekauft, uns geht's kräftig. Alle weg. Thuy schreibt doch seit Jahren rote Zahlen. Er will, er will. Ziehen Sie sich bitte die Hose wieder an. Ihr macht's doch nicht mehr lang. Ziehen Sie sich der Shirt wieder an. Das dauert doch nicht mehr lang und ihr seid am Boden. Sie haben eine Fahne, wir haben noch getrunken. Hier, United Airlines, Arab Airlines, United Arab Lines sind noch alle weg hier. Stay calm, please, just calm. Fass mich nicht an! Fass mich nicht an! Mein Geld kriegt ihr nicht! So läuft's doch, die ganzen Reisen, kein Mensch wer will mehr reisen. Ich glaube nicht, nur weil Air Berlin, weil du gestern mal bei Bild.de gelandet bist, aus Versehen, weil du auf ein Pop-up geklickt hast, wo bestand, dass er Berlin pleite ist. Ja, okay, aber dann hier dieses ganze jetzt aber weg.de oder nicht sie weg.de. Ab in den Urlaub, jetzt aber wirklich in den Urlaub. Jetzt aber es wird zeitig, zeitig in den Urlaub zu gehen. Jetzt aber mal in den Bindestrich Urlaub.de. Kein Wunder, dass sie keinen Erfolg haben, weil es einfach beschissen klingt. Einfach Bullshit. So, und in Zukunft heißen die alle nur palme.de. Was ist Ihre Firmen-Mail-Adresse? Ja, sabine.klassen.at ab in den minus urlaub.net. Minus in minus den minus unterstrich urlaub, die war schon weg. Urla.ub. Wir mussten dafür den Staat, Umbanda, mussten wir fragen, ob sie uns die zur Verfügung stellen. Das hat mich einfach noch geflasht, ich sag das jetzt auch wieder, weil es gerade aktuell wird, Bulli-Parade, damals die URL, ich glaube, das war der erste URL-Gag, war bulli-parade.de, war genial einfach, als Kind dachte ich mir, para, para, para, para, und zwei Jahre später dachte ich mir, ach ja, Parade, das ist genial einfach. Irgendwann hätte auch sein können, dass man statt dieses WWWs auch irgendwann das DE hinten weglässt. Dann hätten die doof geguckt, dann hätten die doof in die Rücke geguckt mit dem Bulli-Para. Ja, jetzt hängen wir an dieser scheiß Adresse. Das stimmt, wir hätten die wahrscheinlich die Sendung umnehmen müssen. Bald kommt der Kinofilm Bulli-Para. Ist es für dich nochmal so ein Blick in die Vergangenheit oder sagst du, mit dem Rotz will ich gar nichts mitzutun? Mit dem Rotz wollte ich nie was zu tun haben so gern. Ich fand, Judas Manitou fand ich immer cool eine Zeit lang. Aber ein Humor, der mir, ich habe das vor ein paar Monaten noch mal geguckt und dachte mir, weil es immer pro sieben wiederholt wird, denke ich mir, das ist echt, das ist wirklich der Abgrund der Comedy eigentlich. Deswegen sind nette Gags bei, Sky Dumont nailed den Film wirklich, aber alles andere schon fragwürdige
Gags. Ich habe das früher gerne geschaut,
Billy Parade hatte ich als CD und ich habe dann auch hier
von wegen auf der
Moldau Gustav,
Gust Gustav konnte ich komplett auswendig und mit
meinen Freunden singen, das war eine tolle Zeit,
aber Money To fand ich noch cool, alles danach fand ich
scheiße und jetzt auch interessant, jetzt noch mal
in dieses Humorvakuum Deutschland, Deutschland ist ein Humorvakuum. Ohne Scheiß. Und wir haben die grösste News da diesbezüglich, das, was mich aus den Socken gehauen hat. Wir haben nämlich endlich die Frage beantwortet bekommen, und es war ja schon ein bisschen, stand es auch so im Raum, es ist auch nicht für viele nicht die Überraschung. Michael Kessler ist der deutsche Jerry Seinfeld. Ja, das war ja schon, das habe ich ja schon vor Jahren gesagt. Der deutsche Jerry Seinfeld, klar. So, und zwar hat er, und das ZDF Neo hat schamlos Comedians in Cars Getting Coffee geklaut, ohne es zu erwähnen. Es gibt keinen Credit. Ich habe alle Interviews gelesen zu dem Format, alle Fernsehkritiken zu diesem Format, nicht nur DWDL, dieses Medien Medienwebsite, Medienmagazin erwähnt einmal Comedians in Cars Getting Gettin' Coffee. Also Comedians in Cars, Gettin' Coffee ist eine amerikanische Sendung mit Jerry Seinfeld, der mit Comedians in alte Autos geht und dann reden die so gleichzeitig über Autos, weil Jerry Seinfeld ist ja auch ein Autosabler. Zu dem Format wollte ich gleich noch kommen. Ja, also tendenziell, kennt das aber wahrscheinlich alle von euch, ein Talk, ein Drive-and-Talk-Format und dann trinken sie alle Kaffee mit netten kleinen Zwischenbildern. Louis C.K. war zu Gast, Barack Obama war zu Gast. Barack Obama war zu Gast, riesen Format und auch in der Jugend bekannt. Und jetzt hat sich Kessler gedacht, das mache ich auch, und er hat es gemacht und es ist erschreckend gleich, ohne, also dann auch so gleich, dass es wirklich eine Frechheit ist, das nicht mehr zu erwähnen, Auch im Abspann steht es nicht drin. Das finde ich auch. Ich habe generell da gar nicht so... Hast du es mal gesehen? Ich habe es gesehen, ja. Also den Namen finde ich auch erst mal komplett bescheuert. Sitzheizung gibt es nicht. Sitzheizung gibt es nicht, heißt die Sendung. Also wirklich, das rollt von der Zunge wie eine Lawine im Dezember. Das ist wirklich, vor allem, ich habe ja nichts, generell nichts dagegen, dass Leute Formatenehmen und benutzen. Und ich finde, es kommt dann trotzdem noch immer darauf an, wie man sie füllt. Ich meine, im Endeffekt ist es ein Talk im Auto. Die Idee ist jetzt nicht unfassbar. Stromberg ist ein gutes Beispiel fürs Clown. Auch nicht erwähnt. Gab es auch ein Riesenproblem nachher. Im Endeffekt war auch Rudi Gervais noch im Abspann. Die nächsten paar Staffeln wurde er noch erwähnt. Pastewka, CurbAthusiasm, sind ja alles gute Beispiele, wie es laufen kann.
Ja, aber das ist für mich dann so der Ding, wo ich gar nicht mehr per se sage, das ist geklaut, solange man dazu steht und sagt, hey, das ist eine Vase, wir befüllen die neue. Und klar, wir klauen die Vase, aber trotzdem ist ja noch was anderes. Es ist ja oft so, dass Leuten Diebstahl vorgeworfen wird bei kreativen Mitteln, die, also zum Beispiel, jeder hat schon tausendmal die Szene gesehen, ein Paar, eine Frau und ein Mann sind kurz davor, sich zu küssen, und dann kommt irgendwas und unterbricht sie kurz, bevor sie sich küssen. So, in diesem Moment hat man schon tausendmal gesehen in verschiedenen Filmen und dann Parodien und so. Jetzt könnte man ja sagen, die Szene ist ja jetzt geklaut aus Film A und B. Wenn du jetzt einen Film drehst, drehst du einen Indie-Film und dann kommt diese Szene und dann die beiden Protagonisten sind kurz davor zu küssen und dann kommt plötzlich irgendwas und dann bricht sie. Dann können sie ja sagen, die Szene ist geklaut. Aber das Interessante, man hat die Szene schon hundertmal gesehen und wahrscheinlich hat man schon hundertmal gesagt, oh Gott, die wieder, lame. Man hat aber schon hundertmal gesagt, ah fuck, ich hätte so gern gewollt, dass sie sich küssen. Der Wert dieser Szene hängt nicht an der Szene selbst, sondern wie die Liebesbeziehung davor aufgebaut wurde, wie die Charaktere gezeichnet wurden. Ob man in dem Moment dann sagt, ah geil, die Szene hat total gut funktioniert oder sie hat nicht funktioniert. Dieser Moment, kurz vorm Küssen unterbrechen, alleine ist nichts wert. Den zu klauen ist auch nicht verwerflich, weil er ist noch nicht der Inhalt der eigentlichen Szene. Der Inhalt ist, warum will man, dass sie sich küssen? Will man denn, dass sie sich küssen? Warum ist man denn emotional so involviert? Das heißt, wenn es jetzt in einem Film vorkommt und jemand schreibt in den YouTube-Kommentaren, die Szene ist geklaut, weil die habe ich schon da gesehen. Nein, es ist Bullshit. Es gibt einfach kreative, stilistische Werkzeuge und Mittel, die man einsetzt, aber die Werkzeuge stehen nicht für sich, die muss man immer noch gut einsetzen. Übrigens auch bei, spannende Sache, vor allem bei Spider-Man Homecoming, ein Film, den ich unfassbar gut fand, überraschenderweise, unfassbar lustiger Film. Und da gab es auch eine Szene, wie Spider-Man nach Hause kommt, sich dann auszieht und sein Kumpel da ist und sieht, dass er Spider-Man ist, den Lego Todesodesstern fallen lässt und sieht dann, und dann sind die beiden, er ist oberkörperfrei mit seinem besten Freund in seinem Schlafzimmer, dann kommt Aunt May hinein und sieht halt ihn oberkörperfrei da stehen, hat man auch schon tausendmal gesehen, aber es war trotzdem lustig, vor allem weil sie dann nichts dazu gesagt hat. Sie haben sich den einfachen Gag dann gespart zu sagen, aha, was ist denn hier bei euch los oder diesen stille fragenden Blick zugeworfen, sondern sie hat einfach ihren Satz gesagt, Essen ist gleich fertig gegangen, das war natürlich cool. Absolut, gerade in der Comedy gibt es solche Sachen, die tausendmal immer wieder benutzt werden und es ist an sich nicht verwerflich. Fangen wir uns ja auch andauernd. Und es ist an sich nicht verwerflich, auch dieses Community Cars, Gelling Coffees, wäre in dem Moment für mich völlig enorm, wenn ich sage, hey, ich liebe die Show, ich finde es richtig geil und die Show lebt ja von den Gästen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass das jetzt irgendwie eins zu eins kopiert ist, weil jeder Gast macht die Sendung zu einer komplett anderen Sendung. Aber da würde ich dir ein bisschen widersprechen. Also zum einen zu sagen, das Format ist cool, das würde ich auch gerne machen, verstehe ich und finde ich auch cool und unterstützenswert. Aber dann ist es halt auch so, dass Jerry Seinfeld unfassbar Car-Sammler ist. Und er ist auch ziemlich charismatisch. Er ist ziemlich lustig, charismatisch und er ist halt ein Autosammler, eine Porsche-Sammlung. Und dem kauft man das halt voll ab. Da ist das Format dann sehr, sehr Jerry Seinfeld gebunden. In dem Moment, wo Michael Kessler sagt, weißt du, Annette Frier, warum ich dir dieses Auto ausgesucht habe, kaufe ich dir nichts ab. Und das ist genau der Punkt, wo man sagt, Alter, das passt auch nicht mehr. Du kannst vor allem auch dieses Format übernehmen, ohne sowas zu machen, ohne die gleiche Musik zu nehmen, ohne die gleichen Zwischenschnitte zu nehmen, ohne exakt die gleichen Sachen zu sagen, wie, weißt du, warum ich dieses Auto rausgesucht habe? Oder in Interviews zu behaupten, wir haben einfach nach Wegen gesucht, locker mit Gästen zu sprechen und im Auto hast du halt immer Dinge, die du siehst, in der Umwelt, die dich beeinflussen. Deswegen fand mir das eine gute Idee. So was zu sagen ist so billig und dann halt auch die gleiche Musik zu nehmen und dann gehen die halt statt Kaffee zu trinken essen mit Leuten, was lustigerweise die einzige Abänderung ist und das einzige, was unfassbar dämlich ist, einfach sehr schlecht, eine schlechte Idee, weil du halt beim Essen nicht reden kannst. Und die halt, die unfassbar zerschnitten sind dann diese Gespräche und dann essen die halt und dann ist halt auch stille und so. Und dann nehmen die halt gleich einen Zwittenschnitt auf, wie das Essen gemacht wird und so und wie das Steak umgebraten wird, halt genauso wie diese Detail-Shots von dem Kaffee, der abgefüllt wird und so, der geräustet wird. Das ist halt so einfach. Und wie kann man denn heutzutage wirklich denken, dass man damit durchkommt? Also wirklich, wie diese Leute denken so, nein, nein, nein, wir erwähnen nirgendwo Jerry Seinfeld und so und es passt schon. Wie kann man denn davon ausgehen, dass einem das nicht um die Ohren fliegt? Es ist doch so offensichtlich, dass jeder heutzutage und vor allem nicht nur Candy-Leute alles, sondern sie haben einen enormen Drang, Leute da zu callen, wenn sie was falsch machen. Jeder Trottel, der auch nur im Ansatz hat, wird sich einen Account sofort anlegen,
die wollen sofort sagen, das ist geklaut, das ist geklaut.
Du hast eine enorme Motivation, dich zu profilieren,
damit das du schon kennst. Total falsch.
Genau, und deswegen, ich würde zustimmen,
das Format zu übernehmen,
in gewissen Weisen, natürlich ist es auch cool und unterstützungswert, aber nicht in der Weise,
wie sie es getan haben. Und dann kommt dann noch hinzu,
dass die Leute
dem Format nicht gerecht werden. In keinster Weise. Die erste Folge ist Bastian Pasewka, ich bin großer Bastian Pasewka-Fan, aber trotzdem, es funktioniert nicht so. Es ist so schwer, es ist so einfach zu sagen, ja, die Amerikaner sind halt cool und lässig und Performer und die Deutschen nicht. Erfasst das Problem auch nicht ganz, aber irgendwie hat man das Gefühl, dass einfach kein komplettes Ding ist. Aber zum Thema Formatklau, ich habe ja zum Beispiel auch den Podcast Last September Monaco, ist ja auch ein Konzept von einem neusehnischen Podcast. Geklaut! Eins zu eins geklaut, weil ich das Konzept cool fand und sagte, hey, wir haben was komplett eigenes draus gemacht, weil das Konzept ja nur ein Gefäss ist, das man selber füllt. Wir haben ja von Anfang an gesagt, hey, das Format ist geklaut. Podcast-Dufo ist auch nur fest und flauschig. Es ist auch fest und flauschig und es ist auch einfach keine
große Schöpfungshöhe. Von daher habe ich gar nichts
dagegen, dass man sagt, klaut, wenn man einfach nicht so
tut, als würde man nicht klauen, weil das macht so
lächerlich. Und dann zu sagen,
es ist seine eigene Leistung, auf die Idee zu kommen,
kommen zu sein, ist einfach Bullshit.
Das haben sie nicht gesagt, aber es ist schon,
dann habe ich auch die Redakteurin angeschrieben,
sogar, weil ich die kannte.
Lass uns die mal einladen. Ey, Podcast-Ufo-Investigativ! Ja. Aber das ist schon krass. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehrin angeschrieben, sogar, weil ich die kannte. Lass uns die mal einladen. Ey, Podcast-Ufo-Investigativ. Ja, aber das ist schon krass. Das ist wirklich ganz furchtbar gelaufen. Und auch leider wieder so ein Zeuge davon, dass viel falsch läuft. Schrecklich. Wie kommen wir aus dieser Jauche-Grube des deutschen Humors zu lustigen Gags? Mit einer Apropos-Überleitung. Apropos Clown. Stephen King hat ein Buch geschrieben über Clowns. Hast du Der dunkle Turm von Stephen King schon gesehen? Nein. Ja, scheiße. Kommt auch bald It, kommt auch bald in die Kinos. Das stimmt, Stephen King ist wieder total drin. Wer hat den eigentlich, wer hat den wieder modern gemacht? War Stranger Things so ein bisschen? Schon, oder? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich habe mit Stephen King so gut wie keinen Kontakt. Doch, ich finde den super. Es ist halt null anspruchsvoll, aber naja, das stimmt nicht. Also die meisten Bücher. Und er hat ja ein Buch über das Schreiben geschrieben. Und das ist total geil. Das kann sich eigentlich jeder, auch jemand, der nicht Autor sein will, kann sich das ruhig mal durchlesen. Das ist so cool, wie er, also es ist viel auch über seine Jugend, das kann man alles skippen, aber es ist auch viel über das Schreiben, wo er einfach sagt, einfach einfache Tipps gibt zum Schreiben. Und er sagt halt ganz offen, dass er am Anfang nicht weiß, wie das Buch endet. Also er schreibt keine Outline, sondern er fängt einfach an. Und dann guckt er, wo die Figuren enden. Und man merkt es auch einfach total. Weil man hat so viele Fragen nach den Büchern und denkt und wüsste die gerne und wünscht sich einfach, dass er sich mehr Gedanken macht am Anfang mit einem Outline und die Dinge, die am Anfang Akt 1 vorgestellt werden, machen wieder Sinn in Akt 3. Nope, keine Chance, er fängt einfach irgendwo an, guckt wo es hinläuft und dann ist er irgendwann am Ende. Das ist schon geil. Und er hat gesagt, man muss jeden Tag zehn Seiten schreiben. Oh. Machst du das? Nee, ich hatte auch mal so eine. Aber du hast mal die Challenge von Ben Schwartz gemacht. Ich hatte mal die 15 Jokes a Day Ben Schwartz Challenge. Ben Schwartz hat mal erzählt, dass er noch bevor er bei Letterman gearbeitet hat, als One-Liner-Autor, hat er jeden Tag 15 Gags geschrieben, und das habe ich auch eine Zeit lang gemacht, da habe ich dann für jeden Tag ein Dokument angelegt und 15 Gags geschrieben, da habe ich, glaube ich, drei Tage durchgehalten und dann hat er immer wieder jeden zweiten Tag ein bisschen was gemacht. Aber irgendwann auch so, das gibt es ja oft, aber man ist einfach so drecksfaul. Es ist auch unfassbar, wie faul man ist. Ich denke mir zum Beispiel auch so was wie so körperliche Sachen. Keine Ahnung, wie weit könnte ich sein, wenn ich mein gesamtes Leben lang einfach jeden Tag einen Liegestütz gemacht hätte. Jeden Tag einen. Oder einen Snickers weggelassen hätteättest. Ja, oder auch nur jeden Tag einen. Ich lebe jetzt seit 26 Jahren, das ist 26 mal 300, ist halt irgendwas im Bereich von 6000. Es würde nichts verändern. 6000 Liegestütze. Du kannst mir nicht erzählen, dass 6000 Liegestütze keinen Einfluss auf dich haben. Wenn du ein Bildst, links, jeden Tag kein Liegestütz, rechts, jeden Tag ein Liegestütz, keinen Einfluss auf dich haben. Ich glaube, wenn du ein Bildst links, jeden Tag kein Liegestütz, rechts jeden Tag ein Liegestütz, ist exakt bist du mit Hut. Ist exakt der gleiche Mensch. Sechstausend Liegestütze gehen nicht einfach so an dir vorbei. Nein, auf jeden Fall du verbrauchst minimal mehr Energie pro Tag. Ja, aber jeden Tag. Und du hast so sehr ausgeprägte Brustmuskulatur, so sehr definierte Brüste, die du dann auch so im Rhythmus kannst, so deine Brustmuskulatur anfangen. Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Kriegt man dann, wenn man so Brustmuskulatur hat, dann auch die Kontrolle darüber? Ey, und ohne Scheiß. Fitnessstudio, Stefan, hat jetzt Kontrolle über seine Brustmuskulatur. Ernsthaft? Ja, aber nicht so gut, dass ich jetzt auf Kommando kann. Aber manchmal liegt man so abends im Bett und dann hat man Wenn ich getasert werde, dann kann ich.
Dann denke ich an, ich denke an Brüste,
denke an Brüste, denke an Brüste,
und plötzlich bewegt sich so eine Brustmuskulatur
von mir. Verstehe. Und dann denkt man so
Wow! Weil ich verstehe auch,
also ich verstehe nicht, du musst ja nur denken,
hebt den linken Arm hoch. Das ist ja was sehr
Automatismen, sehr abgetrieben.
Und wenn du jetzt, wenn du überlegst,
du weißt nicht genau, wie Muskeln funktionieren,
du weißt nicht genau, was du machen musst
mit deinem Kopf, damit die Zeigefinger,
Das ist ein sehr abgetrieben. Und wenn du jetzt, wenn du überlegst, du weißt nicht genau, wie Muskeln funktionieren, du weißt nicht genau, was du machen musst mit deinem Kopf, damit diese Zeige finden. Das ist gelernt. So, aber was denn, wenn sich Muskeln bilden erst? Dann musst du, das ist ja sehr, verstehst du, das ist ein sehr abstraktes Konzept, dieses Muskeln betreiben. Und wenn du Muskeln aufbaust, und ich hatte nie Brustmuskulatur, und jetzt plötzlich musst du dich erst, musst du erst lernen, diese Brust, diese Muskulatur zu betätigen, ist schon irgendwie strange, ein ganz komisches Gefühl. Wie läuft sonst ein Workout so? Also Muskelstefan? Es kam zu einem Zwischenfall. Also erstmal bin ich mit dem Boosted Board ja hingefallen vor einer Woche, wisst ihr ja alle noch. Wir haben es, glaube ich, in der Zeitung gelesen, ja, es war horrende. Und es ist immer noch entzündet, es ist immer noch, ich habe immer noch ein Pflaster drauf, ein Hypoallergenpflaster. Ladies, I'm still on the market. Und dann, ja, bin ich hingefallen, kann deshalb nicht ins Fitnessstudio gehen, weil mein Arm eingeschränkt ist. Aber ich war halt vor ein paar Wochen, das ist mein Fitnessstudio, und da kam es zum Zwischenfall. und zwar ist das passiert, was ich gehofft habe, das nie passiert. Ich war an der Benchpress, und dann kommt plötzlich ein offensichtlich häufiger trainierender Mensch auf mich zu, der sehr viel trainiert, sehr wenig liest, so ein Mensch. Also ganz viele Skillpunkte in Muskeln und wenig Skillpunkte in Seen Kick. Also wenn ihr bei den Simpsons Charakter erstellt, da hättet ihr den ein bisschen dunkelhäutiger gemacht. Okay, warum das? Ist irrelevant für die Story, aber einfach nur, er ist ein bisschen dunkelhäutiger gemacht. Welche Haare, so ein bisschen nach oben? Ja, links und rechts keine Haare, in der Mitte viel. So wie der Freund von Arnold, einfach so. Genau, richtig. Okay, so stellen wir uns den vor. Aber ein bisschen heller, also nicht so unangenehm dunkel. Okay. Ein bisschen heller. So, dann Tanktop, also maximal wenig Ärmeltextil. Dann schön, ja, Johnny-Hose, so eine Nike-Joggy-Hose, eine lange. Und sehr viele Skillpunkte geben auf Trainieren und Disziplin und sehr, sehr wenig in Bildung. Alles klar. So. sehr platt, aber es kommt ungefähr hin. Und dieser Mensch kam dann auch, hat sich auf die Bandpress neben mir gesetzt und hat dann angefangen. Und plötzlich hat er mich angesprochen. Ich dachte mir, bitte, lass das nie vorkommen, ich bete jedes Mal, bitte lass das nie vorkommen, dass mich jemand anspricht. Und so, ja, könntest du mal mit mir gucken, kannst du mir die Stange halten? Ah, wie ist da der Fachbegriff dafür? Kannst du mir kurz helfen. Okay. Das sagen wir, wir auch gerade. Helfen, okay. Kannst du mir kurz helfen. Ah, verrückte Welt. Oder, ich dachte auch, die sagen, kannst du mir kurz mit mir trainieren oder so. Aber das Wort helfen hat mich ein bisschen irritiert. Ich habe mich auf Kuh gemacht, ja klar, klar, klar, kann ich helfen. Und dann läuft halt die ganze Zeit die typische Fitnessstudio-Musik. Das ist die ganze Zeit so ein Tf, Tf, Tf. Und alles, was du da machst, du musst dich nicht verstellen. Ich bin ja kein anderer Mensch. Du bist einfach, du morphst in dieses System Fitnessstudio einfach rein. Allein durch diese Musik, diese ganze Background, alles in diesem Studio macht aus dir so eine typische Morph, macht dich zu so einer Fitnessstudio-Welt und du lässt dich da rein. Du bist einfach nur ein Zahnrad in dieser grossen Proteinwelt. Genau, exakt. Und dann gehe ich da hinter ihn, helfe ihm und genau in dem Moment, wo ich ihm helfe, das Gewicht immer hochzudrücken, weil die lächerlich zu viel nehmen, das ist einfach falsch, diese Menschen, in dem Moment ändert sich die Musik und es ändert sich von der typischen Trance-Musik zu La La Land. Und dann denke ich mir, Leute, was ist denn jetzt passiert? Was zu dem seltsamen Moment, wir haben beide Augenkontakte, plötzlich City of Stars. Ist das natürlich mitgesungen. Ja klar, ausgezogen, direkt shirtless stand ich hinter ihm. Und das war ein ganz, ganz seltsamer Moment. Ich war ihm lächerlich nah, mein Schritt auf seinem Kopfhöhe. Natürlich an den Gedanken, an Emma Stone, Direkterektion bekommen. Direkterektion bekommen. Und ich halte undfe ihm, mit seinem öligen, geflexten Bizeps die Stange immer hochzuhalten. Aber du hältst seine Hände, oder? Natürlich. Du hältst seine Hände an der Stange. Ja. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich ihm richtig geholfen habe, aber das war ganz seltsam. Aber was ist die Idee, du musst ihm helfen zu stemmen? Die nehmen zu viel Gewicht. So, und irgendwann,
die können dann so fünf Bewegungen machen und irgendwann kommen die
halt nicht mehr höher, aber an einem gewissen Punkt.
Und dann musst du denen so leicht helfen, um über so einen gewissen Punkt zu kommen,
damit die Arme sich strecken und die Stange
wieder absetzen können. Weil sonst quetscht die Stange
die irgendwann ein. Solche Menschen würden
alleine, wenn du die alleine lässt,
in diesem Bildestudio versterben.
Das war dann halt der Moment
erreicht. Und dann habe ich ihm geholfen, in dem Moment kommt La La Land. Und dann war es nur noch homoerotisch. Und wir sind fest zusammen. Uns geht es sehr gut, wir sind zusammengezogen. Können jetzt auch adoptieren. Alles klar, dann können die Kinder immer hochheben. Ganz stranger Moment, wo ich dachte, was ist denn jetzt los? Das ist ja sowieso meine Vorstellung von Training. Zum Beispiel, ich kaufe mir einen Fohlen. So. Das hat man mir empfohlen, und jetzt habe ich's. Und dann stemme ich dieses Fohlen. Wer hat sie empfohlen? Dieter Fohlen? Dann stemme ich dieses Fohlen. Ja? Benchpress Fohlen. Ja. So. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich die richtige Folge. Pass auf. Ich stemme dieses Fohlen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ein Wort gerade in meinem Kopf so eine Autokorrektur erlebt und du hast eigentlich irgendwie Gewicht gemeint und mir meinten sie Fohlen. Nee, nee, ich meine Fohlen. Sagst du das gerade die ganze Zeit? Ich meinte tatsächlich Fohlen. Dein Gesicht macht auch eine andere Bewegung als Fohlen. Nee, nee, nee, ich stemme Fohlen. Ja. So, und dann stemme ich jeden Tag einmal das Fohlen. Mhm. Und es wird ja immer grösser, es wird ja irgendwann zum Pferd. Und dann werde ich auch stärker,
weil das Fohlen immer mehr größer wird.
Und dann werde ich automatisch stärker.
Aber halt so ganz
leicht, so eine ganz smoothe Kurve.
Ja, ich glaube nur nicht, dass deine Muskeln sich
äquivalent zu dem Wachsen
des Fohlens steigen, sondern das wird ja
Du meinst, das wächst schneller als meine
Muskeln wachsen? Oder umgekehrt.
Ja, dass ich stärker werde und dann irgendwann das Fohlen ausversehen in die Luft schleudert. Nicht ins Weltall. Wo war eigentlich das Fohlen, das ich empfohlen habe? Daher kommt auch das berühmte Sprichwort, lass das Fohlen nicht ins Weltall schweben. Das stimmt. Ich habe neulich gehört, dass Rehe nicht die weibliche Version des Hirschens sind. Hat mich ... What? What? Klar. Holy shit! Aber du hast ja Bambi gesehen. Ja, genau. Das ist ein Übersetzungsfehler. Das ist nämlich falsch bei Bambi. Bambi ist ein Hirsch. Richtig. Aber einige sind ... Nee, Bambi ist ein Reh. Aber einige sind Hirsch, die haben es nur falsch übersetzt. Daher habe ich das nämlich. Ja, das. Mega verwirrend. Ja, und es gibt tatsächlich, ich dachte, Rehe sind wie eine Kuh. Kuh und Bulle. Das dachte ich, wäre das Äquivalent zu Hirsch und Reh. Nope. Meine ganze Welt bricht in sich zusammen. Wie hast du das erfahren? In diesem Radiobeitrag über Bambi. Du mit deinen Radiobeiträgen, ey. Du hast dein ganzes Wissen aus Radiobeiträgen. Ein vergessenes Medium. Supergut, ey. Das ist das Beste für mich, weil du machst einen Radiosender an und diese Willkürlichkeit, wenn der plötzlich Beiträge aus dem Boden sprießen, plötzlich über Bambi, weil der Jahrestag von Bambi war. Immer diese scheiß Jahrestank. Es war super geil.
Es gibt ja tatsächlich so, das hast du mir mal gezeigt,
als du mich mal journalistisch eingewiesen hast,
es gibt ja tatsächlich eine Seite für Journalisten,
für unkreative Journalisten, ich glaube, die heisst auch unkreativejournalisten.de,
die nicht wissen, was sie machen sollen, und das ist eine Webseite,
auf der lauter aktuelle Anlässe stehen.
Ja.
Heute ist Tag des YX.
So, heute ist Tag des YX. Und da könnt ihr euch anmelden, ganz kurz,
da könnt ihr euch anmelden, und das ist jetzt
lustig, und zwar heißt die Seite,
ah fuck, wie heißt die Seite nochmal,
weißt du das noch? Ne.
Weil ich hab die Zugangsdaten, und es war
von 1Live. Ihr müsst eingeben,
Benutzername ist 1Live,
N1 wie Zahl und dann L-I-V-E
und das Passwort ist
Media Park. Und das hat,
aus irgendeinem Grund habe ich das bekommen,
und da könnt ihr euch, da gibt es ja
Vielen Dank. Eins wie Zahl und dann L-I-V-E und das Passwort ist Mediapark. Und das hat, aus irgendeinem Grund habe ich das bekommen. Und da könnt ihr euch, da gibt es ja, das ist sauteuer und ihr könnt das Passwort ändern von 1Live, aber das macht ihr bitte nicht. Ändert das Passwort mal nicht. Und da könnt ihr euch, da haben die ein Abo und aus irgendeinem Grund habe ich das Passwort und fuck it. Und da könnt ihr euch anmelden und das ist halt für Journalisten, die nicht wissen, was sie sagen sollen.
Und das war mega hilfreich beim Neo Magazin früher, weil ich dann immer wusste, was Up to Date war und wusste, was für Jahrestage sind, wer gerade gestorben ist vor hundert Jahren und so weiter. Das hieß doch irgendwas mit Daily oder so, nicht, oder? Wie hieß das denn nochmal?
Show Prep. Show Prep.
Show Prep. Show Prep. Show Prep?
Show Prep.info.
So.
Eins Live Media Park.
So, heute zum Beispiel.
Das ist immer noch das Passwort, ich fasse es nicht.
Okay.
Und die haben den Premium-Account.
Und alle von euch haben jetzt auch den Premium-Account von Show Prep.
Und da seht ihr heute zum Beispiel. Könnt ihr oben auf Premium klicken und dann Termine heute. Und dann seht ihr da, erster Schultag nach den Sommerferien im Saarland. Heute ist der erste Schultag nach den Sommerferien im Saarland. Oh, da seid ihr wieder in die Schule gegangen, oder? Und schon sind wir relatable, wir sind aktuell, wir sind relevant. Und da muss man jetzt durch irgendwas aus den Fingern saugen, wie das interessant ist. Fussball, Schweiz, Reifeisen, Super League, zweiter Spieltag. Heute, vor 208 Jahren, die Universität Berlin wurde gegründet. Ja, und solche Sachen weist nicht rein. Ja, und genau so war das. Und dann war halt ein Jahrestag von Bambi. Und dann haben die halt darüber erzählt. Moment, aber ganz kurz, welche Tage sind denn heute? Heute ist der Erzähl-einen-Witz-Tag, der Teller-Joke-Day und heute, meine Damen und Herren, ist der Weltachterbahntag, der Rollercoaster-Day. Wie feiert man den? Wow, heute vor 104 Jahren ist die amerikanische Ford Motor Company in Detroit, nimmt das erste Montageband in Betrieb. Namenstage Alfred, Christian, Rochus, Stephanie, Steffen, Stefan! Nein. Stefan mit PH hat heute Namenstag. Ich habe am zweiten Weihnachtsfeiertag nämlich Geburtstag. Namenstag. Namenstag. Da hatten wir Veranstaltungen bei uns in der Stadthalle damals, wurde richtig gefeiert. Da gab es nämlich so eine Party und da bin ich zum DJ gegangen und habe um 0 Uhr gebeten, dass er meinen Namenstag durchsagt. Meine Glückwünsche. Weil alle immer gesagt haben, da haben die mal Happy Birthday gesungen um 0 Uhr halt für die ganzen, die Geburtstag haben, und da habe ich gefragt, ob er meinen Namenstag würdigen kann. Wollte er noch war ja nicht getan ja und dann wurde halt über bambi gesprochen und dann wurden auch leute interviewt die das halt ein traumatisches erlebnis war weil es damals ein krasser film war mit für leute die dann zum ersten die für kinder die mit dem tod konfrontiert wurden und so eine frau erzählt die war damals ein kleines mädchen und die hat erst vor kurzem bambi verstanden weil ihre Mutter hat die VHS-Kassette genommen, den Tod der Mutter rausgeschnitten, wieder zusammengelötet, keine Ahnung, und hat es dann gezeigt. Heißt, die hat die ganze Zeit einen unzusammenhängenden Film geguckt, der die ganze Zeit nur fröhlich war. Ergibt der Film überhaupt Sinn? Ergibt null Sinn. Warum sind plötzlich alle traurig? Alle sind traurig, plötzlich ist Bambi alleine so. Ist es nicht sogar noch grausamer, wenn die Mutter nicht stirbt, sondern einfach weg ist und nicht mehr auftaucht und alleine gelassen hat? Wie furchtbar ist das denn? Das ist echt verrückt. Und der Film hat, glaube ich, nur 500 Wörter, werden gesprochen in dem Film. Alles andere sind Action-Sequenzen und Musik. Und Action-Sequenzen meine ich heftige Fight-Szenen.
Fight-und-Fix-Szenen.
Gibt es eigentlich auch eine Porno-Bambi?
Klar, auf jeden Fall.
Natürlich.
Apropor Porno.
Ja.
Ich hatte neulich ... Oh, jetzt lass ich mal so was von den Hosen.
Wir lassen mal die Hosen ...
Aproporno.
Wir lassen neulich mal ...
In unserer neuen Rubrik Aproporno.
Von Theodor Aporno.
Wir lassen heute mal die Hosen ...
Oh!
Zotige Gags unter der Gürtellinie. Wie soll er aufhören zu singen? Oh, sorry. Also ich glaube, beim Porno-Konsum bin ich halt auf eine neue Art des Pornos offensichtlich gestossen, was ich faszinierend fand und auch sehr originell und innovativ, und zwar serieller Porno, ein seriell erzählender Porno. Schön am Anfang mit einem Was bisher geschah, dann werden die Schauspielernamen und eingeblendet, Regisseur eingeblendet. Wie, Was bisher geschah? Ja, es gibt bisher geschah, außer bei der ersten Folge, da ist es weiss einfach. Nein, es kommt erst bei der zweiten Folge, was bisher geschah. Da sieht man dann die letzte Folge und denkt sich, what ist denn jetzt passiert?
Und dann hast du erst
ungefähr eine Minute dreissig
packende Story mit tollen, tiefständigen
Charakteren, die Intrigen
gegenseitig und dann fallen die sich in den
Rücken und so weiter und dann
beginnt das Euphemismen oder was?
Nee, es ist alles wahr und dann beginnt ein knallter Porno.
So.
Und das Serie erzählt und danach geht es wieder los und dann wird die Geschichte aufgegriffen und was Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, jetzt von hinten nehmen? Und dann ist schwarz und man weiß nicht, what, wie reagiert sie denn jetzt da drauf und so weiter. Und es ist wirklich, kann sogar sein, dass es ein Cliffhanger war, ein echter von dieser Serie. Und dann war ich gebannt und dann habe ich weitergeguckt. Und dann Folge zwei oder Folge drei fing dann an, und das war ein wertverstörendes Erlebnis, dann haben die Fernseher geguckt, diese Leute, um die es da ging. Und dann haben die Fernseher geguckt und es lief Duck Funny. Also diese alte Kinder, diese Nickelodeon. Die alte Sendung. Was ist passiert da in deiner Hose gerade? Einen Riesen-Reständer habe ich jetzt bekommen. Wegen der Musik? Ja, konditioniert. Ich bin jetzt auf Duck Funny konditioniert. Und dann gibt es Patty Mayonnaise. Und sieht schon echt, also die fand ich damals auch schon, sehr attraktiv. Die haben in dem Porno eine normale Folge Duck gesehen. Keine Porno-Folge. Wie das rechtlich, keine Ahnung. Aber bei Porno abgelten eh ganz andere Gesetze. Das ist so eine Grauzone. Das sind einfach die niederländischen Antillen vom Internet. Ganz seltsam. Und dann, ja, dann haben die einfach eine Folge Duck Funny gezeigt. Und wirklich lang, also eine Minute lang guckt man dann Duck Funny mit einem prallen Ständer in den Handen und denkt sich so. Und hört halt auch nicht auf. Du hörst nicht auf, das kannst du mir nicht erzählen. Du pausierst dann nicht, spulst vor und machst dann weiter. Nein, die ganze ist halt sehr verstörend, weil es eine Kinderserie ist. Und ich stehe mir vor, angenommen, die hätten nicht da Quanti gezeigt, sondern Hotel Zack und Cody,
das wäre halt ziemlich uncool dann.
So einen alten Olsen-Twins-Film.
Okay, Leute, jetzt schon langsam geht es auch.
Jetzt reicht es auch.
Es ist technisch gesehen kein Kinderporno, aber im Kontext ist es kritisch.
Und dann lief, jetzt muss ich gerade an diese eine Mutter denken,
die man bei uns kommentiert hat, die meint, sie hat mit ihrer Tochtheim an dem Podcast. Viel Spaß mit der Folge und den Fragen danach. Beste Serie auch. Patty Mayonnaise. Uninteressanter, unmotivierter Hauptfigur. Go! Ja, stimmt, der langweilige Typ. Aber fand ich cool, hat mir immer gut gefallen. Ja, strange. Herr Arnold fand ich auch strange. Aber Pornos haben teilweise so unfassbare Klickzahlen. Es gibt ja manche Portalen, wo die Klickzahlen angezeigt werden, wie bei YouTube. Unfassbar. Also wirklich, was bei uns irgendwie Wopdub irgendwie, wow, 40 Millionen Klicks, stecken die locker weg, einfach überhaupt kein Problem. Da hat wirklich auch so der Miserabelste, da hat er locker seine 20 Millionen Klicks einfach so. Das ist unfassbar. Ja. Das ist absolut unfassbar. Wir haben uns gerade auch in der Redaktion unterhalten, dass es diesen Share-Button ja gibt. Du bei Facebook aber keine nackten Inhalte zeigen kannst, du kannst nur auf Facebook Pornhub-Videos sharen. Aber auf Twitter kannst du knallhart sein. Meine Frage, wer sharet Pornos, dann warum wird es dann, warum kann man das überhaupt bei Facebook sharen, wenn es sofort gelöscht wird? Pornop ist auch knallhart, die wollen das auch. Aber Twitter ist sehr offen, was sowas angeht. Auf Twitter gibt es auch tatsächlich viele pornografische Inhalte, wenn man da mal so ein bisschen der Brotkrümelspur folgt, weil es gibt, wenn du einen erfolgreichen, also ich erkläre es nochmal, wenn du einen erfolgreichen Tweet hast, dann werden auch manchmal Pornobots retweeten den oder binden den ein. Ich weiß nicht, kommen so Kommentare wie Oha Ausrufezeichen. Ja genau, oder You won't believe oder ein Punkt, Punkt, Punkt und dann lauter Smileys und dann so dein Tweet und denkst dir, what? Und wenn du dieser Krümelspur mal folgst, dann kommst du wirklich in Hardcore-Porno-Ecken, die es auf Twitter gibt und die anscheinend auch existieren dürfen. Bei Instagram Live auch. Da kann man auch mal, wenn du da auf das Suchfeld gehst und dann so ein paar Klicks brauchst du nur, um einfach Leuten, auch offensichtlich jugendlichen Menschen, beim Masturbieren zuzugucken. Ich glaube, wenn du in deine Plattform nicht irgendwie einen dicken Wall einbaust, dringt sich Porno so voll durch alle Ritzen durch. Du hast sofort, auch wenn du einfach irgendwie ein ganz harmloses Angebot machst, so hey, ich würde gerne eine Carsharing-Plattform machen, so Instant-Bang-Bus. Hier 50 Pornos, hier 50, hier schön Titten ins Gesicht, zack und einfach, ja, wir bieten Bank-Bus-Fahrt und dann so, wow, Leute, ich wollte doch nur so. Das Internet ist wie so ein anstrengender Freund, der dir immer so eine Frau andrehen will, eigentlich auch so. Eigentlich ist das Internet wie dein Penis, du willst eigentlich nur über ganz schöne Dinge nachdenken, aber es ist so, auch mit dem Geräusch, die ganze Zeit, einfach die Fresse. Du hast letztens dein Auto gechared, stimmt das? Nee, ich habe jetzt die App entdeckt. Oh, wie geht es eigentlich bei die Storyline von Pleine, Stefan? Wie geht es da eigentlich weiter? Wieder voll dabei. Ist es wieder voll im Saft? Ja, ganz seltsam. Ich habe jetzt dieses, am Monatsende geht es mir schlecht, am Monatsanfang geht es mir wieder sehr gut. Das Leben führe ich jetzt, was ich noch nie dachte, dass ich das jetzt mal führen würde, weil ich dachte, so viel gibst du nicht aus. Doch, hat aber ein bisschen damit zu tun, weil ich halt viel langsam in die Selbstständigkeit abdrifte komplett und halt auch alles selber bezahle, alle Telefonrechnungen, alle Strom, Gas, Erdöl, diese ganzen Sachen, die man halt braucht und Autorechnungen. Warum sagt man eigentlich Erdöl? Wo kommt denn das andere Öl her? Aus dem Himmel oder was? Ist das Ding an? Hallo? Sorry. Wo sind denn alle? Hallo? Wo kommt denn das eigentlich Erdöl? Hey! Ich finde es gut, dass ich mittlerweile bestraft werde, dass ich Gags mache. Das ist die Dynamik, die man haben will. So leichter zieht ein Podcast-Super. Gags sind so
voll verboten eigentlich. Gags sind so
verboten eigentlich. Ja, stimmt schon ein bisschen.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn du kein Geld mehr hast,
kannst du immer noch bei Michael Kessler mitfahren.
Wow.
Mach nochmal die Grillen.
Nein, du hast sie anders gemacht.
Falsch.
S-R-I-P.
So machen doch Grillen. S-r-i-p. S-r-i-p. Oder ist es relativ nah dran. S-r-i-p.
Ja, es klingt wie eine englische Grille, die das TH perfektioniert hat. S-r-i-p.p, rrrrp, rrrrp, rrrrp, rrrrp, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrrr, rrr Pro Sound nur neunundneunzig Cent. Bezahlen Sie über Patreon. Hören Sie jetzt. Eine Flasche wird geöffnet.
Wir müssen glaube ich ein bisschen mit dem Preis runtergehen.
Ein Rasenmäher.
Ist relativ schnell aus Kabel gefahren.
Ein Delfin.
Stone Delfin.
Der hat einen Regenschirm. Scheiss Loch, alle.
Da haben alle Loch im Rücken.
Die laufen auf Land rum.
Loch im Rücken. Das Letzte, was du brauchst, ich stelle mir so vor, wenn jemand, es gibt so ein Schlimmendes im Film, wo jemand seinem Schlüssel ins Wasser fällt und das Einzige, was er kriegt, ist, der Ozean lacht ihn aus durch Delfine. Halt die, fickt die einfach. Mein Gott. Fickt euch einfach. Was meinst du, aus welchen Tieren hat man versucht zu reiten, bevor man sich aufs Pferd geeinigt hat? Delfin war noch 100%, also eine Wasserkavallerie, unersetzbar. Straußen, ich glaube Straußen waren sehr häufig, lange mit dabei, bis man dachte, saugefährlich. Ich glaube, man muss da auch immer so, ich habe immer dieses Bild, wie Vögel Augen auspicken wollen. Die drehen sich doch, wenn man sich auf Straußen setzt, in meinem Kopf drehen sie sofort und picken die beide Augen aus. Und dann hört man eine Vorstellung noch auf, weil ich da nichts mehr sehe ab dem Zeitpunkt, das stelle ich mir mit vor. Und dann, das ist ein Problem, deswegen denke ich mir immer, haben die so riesen Helme aufgehabt, konnten dann nicht mehr sehen und gesagt, komm, das ist mit dem Straussen, das ist eine scheiss Idee. Absolut, wir haben ja letzte Woche ohnehin darüber gesprochen, dass die Geschichte einseitig geschrieben ist und in unserer einer neuen Kategorie was die Geschichte vergast. Was mir die Geschichte vergast hat. Die Straußen-Kavallerie und die Delfin-Kavallerie. Hundertprozentig. Ich nehme vor allem die Straußen vor mit so einem kleinen Helm. Die man, damit die sich auch geschützt haben und vorne dann so ein schönes Kreuzzeichen von den Kreuzzügen, die Straußenzüge. Da ist man vor allem, das ist doch furchterregend, wenn so diese Straussen, die können auch unfassbar schnell rennen, rennen die schneller als Pferde, ich glaube schon.
Ich glaube, die bouncen halt zu schnell.
Und die lenken halt mit den Flügeln. Die lenken halt damit. Also wenn die die Richtung ändern, die können massiv schnell die Richtung ändern, weil die halt dann die Flügel so aufstellen. Das ist ganz abgefahren.
Wirklich?
Ja, ja, ja. Die lenken mit den Flügeln und laufen unfassbar schnell. Die haben ja auch diese richtig, diese Oberschenkel, die sind
grösser als dein ganzer Körper. Die sind so trämiert,
so lächerlich, die sind auch so super definiert
und laufen dann so ganz schnell rum und lenken
mit den Flügeln und wenn die auf so einer Herde
Strauss auf sich zuläuft, ich würde sofort
die Flucht antreten. Ich würde sofort totstellen.
Es gibt ja zwei Strebertiere,
Bienen und Pferde. Pferde
können mehr Last tragen, als sie eigentlich müssten, deswegen können sie Menschen tragen. Und die haben lächerlich viel Komission. Wenn du dich jetzt auf einen Tiger draufsetzt, dann hängt der auf dem Boden und sagt, Alter, wohin führt das jetzt? So, passiert nichts. Pferd denkt sich, oh, das spüre ich kaum, laufe ich weg, habe ein starres Kreuz im Gegensatz zu Raubkatzen. So, zweites Tier, Biene. Sehr eloquent, denkt es. Zweites Tier, Biene.
Biene produziert mehr Honig, als es braucht.
Mensch klaut Honig.
Was gibt es noch für Tiere da draußen, die einfach zu kassen, dem man helfen kann?
Aber das kann man als Mensch schlecht nutzbar machen.
Naja, wenn du viele Ameisen, können auch dein Haus wegtragen.
Weil eine Ameise kann mehr als das 300-Fache ihres Körpergewichts tragen.
Also potenziert auf eine Million Ameisen.
Stimmt, wenn man Ameisen kontrollieren könnte.
Ja, die will... kann mehr als das 300-Fache ihres Körpergewichts tragen, also potenziert auf eine Million Ameisen.
Stimmt, wenn man nur Ameisen kontrollieren könnte.
Ja, die würden einfach Dinge wegtragen.
Wie bei Flutterkaribik 3 hat das schon verstanden.
Das ganze Schiff wird weggetragen von diesen Krebsen.
Da denke ich mir, gute Idee.
Also die nächste militärische Zukunft nach der Atombombe sind Ameisen, die einfach den Gegner wegtragen. Leute, unser Panzer. Was? Moment, unsere Hauptstadt wird weggetragen! Hey, Leute! Ach Gott, jetzt ist es weg. Ah nein, wo ist unser Schützenraben? Hast du früher Stronghold 2 gespielt? Ja. Bei Stronghold 2 konnte man den Meuchelmörder einsetzen und der war halt unsichtbar für den Gegner. Das heißt, du konntest ihn irgendwo hinschicken, der war unsichtbar, konnte jemanden angreifen. Und dann habe ich einfach immer dann den Gegner Bergfried angreifen, den König angreifen, und dann konntest du den umbringen. Und dann ist ja, wenn er dann besiegt wurde, die ganze Stadt sofort weg. Heißt, ganz oft kam es bei Stronger dazu, dass plötzlich deine Stadt weg war, weil du eingenommen wurdest. Und dann dachte ich mir, wenn das historisch akkurat wäre, wie lustig wäre das dann. Was ist denn jetzt gerade passiert? Ah, Meuchelmörder. Okay. Sind Meuchelmörder ein grösseres Problem, als uns die Geschichte weismachen will? Ich glaube nicht. Ich frage mich immerhin, warum so politische Führer nicht viel häufiger ermordet wurden. Es gibt doch immer, im besten Fall hast du doch eine Opposition von so 30 Prozent oder sowas. Es gibt doch immer Leute, die dich tot haben wollen. Ist das so schwer? Außer Disney-Prinzessinnen. Da müsste man eigentlich mal so einen Putsch machen, so einen Militärputsch gegen Cinderella. Gegen Fucking Dornröschen, hey! Power to the people! Ich will auch nicht wissen, wenn man mal Cinderella guckt, oder so Lissy, wie war es?
Sissy, Sissy.
So was, ja, okay.
Nein, aber ich mach mal mit.
Was waren denn noch so Königin, Cinderella, die von Frozen, waren doch alle so Königinnen,
keine Ahnung, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Fun Fact, Sissy hatte so lange Haare, dass sie Nackenschmerzen hatte, weil die Haare
so schwer waren.
Dankeschön, Frau und hinwählen.
Ich war im Sissy-Museum, ich war im Sissy Pferd. Ich war im Sissi-Museum.
Ernsthaft?
Im Sissi-Museum.
Komm, mach ein bisschen mit, okay?
Ich habe auch keinen guten Tag.
Ist okay.
Und dann angenommen, die zeigen dann mal so die süssste Cinderella mit den grossen Augen
und den kleinen Problemen.
Oh, passen die Schuhe nicht und die Stiefmütter, es sind immer Stiefmütter, ärgern einen und dann haben die Probleme, ich habe das nie gesehen im Film. Und dann schreitest du halt so zur leidenden Bevölkerung und was die einfach für diese Prinzessinnen immer für eine scheiß Politik eigentlich machen, weil die die ganze Zeit mit ihren scheiß Prinzessinnen-Problemen zu tun haben. Und das Volk von Disney-Präschen leidet, so kleine Mädchen und kleine Jungen mit so grossen Augen einfach, die zu Tode hungern. Grossen Augen. Wie mit grossen Augen zu T haben. Und das Volk von diesen Disney-Prinzesen leidet. So kleine Mädchen, kleine Jungen mit so grossen Augen einfach, die zu Tode hungern. Die mit grossen Augen zu Tode hungern. Augen kann man nicht essen, schade. Und dann einfach da sitzen und Probleme haben. Und dann die Disney-Prinzessin Stiefmütter sind ärgerlich. Das ist doch scheiße. Die tanzen auch mit dem Löwen, der Löwe tanzt mit dem Mädchen, was soll das sein? Das ist eine Regierung oder was? Das ist unsere Regierung? Man sieht so die ganzen Bauern und dann haben die Probleme und überall steckt Jauche auf. Und dann schwenkt man so zu diesem Disney-Schloss rüber, wo einfach man so Disco-Licht raussieht und so eine Musical-Nummer raushört. Ja genau, also alle Kameras sind da aufgerichtet. Let it go, let it go! Und man hört so ganz in der Ferne aus dem Disney-Schloss den Bass leise dröhnen. Das wäre mal ein sozial kritischer Cartoon, so ganz viele Kameras, die auf Cinderella-Schloss gerichtet sind, aber die leidenden Menschen draußen die Filmen, niemand. Aber ich finde, der Schwenk rüber und dann hört man diesen tiefen Bass und die Disco-Kuh. Und auch dieser große Stern, der über das Schloss fliegt. Ja genau, nicht über die armen Bevölkerung. Oder der Stern trifft dann noch so die Bevölkerung. Oh, der landet als Komet in der Bevölkerung. Ja genau, und die können nicht essen, weil sie keine Zähne mehr haben. So, Zeitkritik, Potenzum. Zeitkritik, ich hasse unsere Zeit, alles ist schlecht, es sollte wieder sein, wie es früher war, alles ist schlecht, die Zeiten müssen sich ändern, weg damit! Heute haben ja die YouTuber, heute war ja das grosse Event, YouTuber interviewen Angela Merkel.
Habe ich mir das sogar angeguckt.
Aber war es nicht eher, Angela Merkel interviewt YouTuber?
Oh, du bist so ein ...
Du bist so ein ...
Satire, filetierende, gesellschaftskritisierende Frage.
Du schaffst es immer wieder, die Sachverhalte so auf den Kopf zu stellen,
dass sich ganz neue Perspektiven ergeben.
Dass es gar keinen Sinn mehr ergibt.
Kann ich noch eine Portion haben?
So lecker.
Das ist grossartig einfach.
Ja, was erwartet man denn? Da hast du halt vier verängstigte Leute.
Worauf willst du hinaus jetzt eigentlich?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber da dachte ich mir so,
man macht sich ja schnell lustig über die YouTuber dann so,
die stellen nur dumme Fragen.
Ja, passiert am schnellen.
Die stellen dann so Fragen wie, wie stehen sie zu Erdogan, wo die Politik nichts anderes zu tun hat, als konstant Pressemitteilungen zu machen, was sie von Erdogan halten. Das sind Fragen, die haben die schon tausendmal beantwortet und stellt jetzt halt nochmal Alexi Beksi die Frage, was halten sie von Erdogan. Aber er stellt sich eloquenter. Genau dasselbe, noch mal, was sie auch immer sagt. Aber er stellt sich wie ein Jugendlicher, und auch die Jugendlichen lesen dann mal die Pressen.
Was soll Angela Merkel denn sagen so?
Manchmal denke ich mir so, die würde auch gerne über andere Themen reden, aber so, ja, ich sage dasselbe. Wenn sie Alexi Bexzi pöst sich unfassbar auch so jugendlich dann antwortet zurück, weil sie sonst nie so antworten kann. Alexi Bexzi fragt, was halten sie von Erdogan? Ach, ganz im Ernst, den mag ich überhaupt nicht. Ohne Scheiß. Was ein Idiot, voll johin, der unterdrückt da alle Menschen, Alter. Das kann ich nicht mehr tolerieren, aber ich kann auch nicht so offen reden, weil das würde die diplomatischen Beziehungen zerstören. Aber dann denke ich mir auch immer, so über die zu lachen ist einfach. Ich weiß auch nicht, was ich Angela Merkel fragen würde. Ich meine, das könnte ja sein, Angela Merkel in der großen Podcastsache. Und ihr darf eine Frage stellen. Was würdest du ihr stellen für eine Frage? Ich würde sie was Privates fragen. Einfach mal die Person hinter der Maske. Einfach mal so, hey, was machen Sie, schauen Sie House of Cards
und mögen Sie das wieder die Politik?
Wie akkurat ist House of Cards?
Sowas würde ich stellen, weil das ist wirklich wichtig.
Aber ich habe auch keine Ahnung.
Ich mache mich über Dinge lustig, von denen ich keine Ahnung habe.
Beschreibt das nicht unsere Satiren?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Angela Merkel, die ist wohl mal vor ihrer Wahl zur Bundeskanzlerin,
vor der ersten Kandidatur, ist sie zu ...
Ich meine, es war Cameron gegangen.
James oder David?
James.
Hat gesagt, den Film fand ich richtig gut.
Hat mir richtig gefallen.
Aber ohne den ...
Warum ist sie runtergegangen?
Wer ist auch ohne den Eisberg gegangen?
Eben.
Und dann hat sie gefragt, den britischen Premier,
hör mal, ich würde wirklich wahnsinnig gerne Bundeskanzlerin werden, ich glaube, ich kann das auch gut, aber ich bin einfach zu uncharismatisch. Das hat die gesagt. Und ich finde, das zeugt von so viel Stärke, diese Schwäche zuzugeben. Ja. Aber was hat James Cameron dann gesagt? Ich spreche kein Deutsch, hat er gesagt. Auf Deutsch. Wie wär's, wenn du dich an so eine Tür hängst in eiskalten Wasser? Alter, der Film ist zwölf Jahre her. Wenn du so eine Kette hast, so eine blaue Kette, alter, niemand will das mehr sehen. Niemand. Aber das fand ich beeindruckend, weil es viel über die Person Merkel sagt. Ich meine, was die Person hinter, wie du schon ansprichst, die Maske Merkel, die Mami. Weil dahinter ist doch eigentlich eine Frau wie du und ich, die sehr viel weiss, aber halt uncharismatisch ist und um ihre Schwäche weiss und das so stärker macht mittlerweile. Finde ich gut, finde ich stark, finde ich unterstützenswert. Wirst du sie wählen? Weiß ich nicht. Was ist denn deine Prognose für die Bundestagswahl? Wird wieder gewählt werden? Ich glaube, es wird wieder gewählt werden, es wird wieder Prozente hageln. Meinst du, es wird diesmal ein Tortendiagramm geben oder so eine andere Art von Diagramm? Balken und Torten. Balken und Torten. Die Bato. Die klassische Bato-Wahl. Vielleicht so ein paar, wo es nach rechts und links geht, wo man nicht genau, wo es sehr kompliziert ist, wo man ein bisschen länger hingucken muss. So Punkte vielleicht, so Kreise? Nee, nee, nee. Kreise? Wird schon abgesehen werden. Wirklich? Nee. Kreise so nebeneinander? Ich würde gerne ein Balkendiagramm, darüber, wie selten diese Punktdiagramme bei dieser Wahl vorgekommen werden. Oder ein Balkendiagramm zwischen Tortendiagramm und Balkendiagramm. Wie viele Balken und Tortendiagramme es gibt. Einmal als Torte, einmal als Balken. Und dann gucken, was gewinnt. Meinst du, man sieht dann so den Bundestag und dann sind die Stühle so eingefärbt, wo die Leute sitzen könnten und man denkt sich, vielleicht setzen die auch anders hin, vielleicht setzen sich alle in die letzte Reihe. Gut sind diese Boxplot-Diagramme,
wo das
arithmetische Mittel und das metrische
Mittel und das
andere Mittel da drin sind.
Und dann sieht man halt, wie
Gemeinverteilung ist. Das ist clever.
Das finde ich richtig gut. Da kann man viele Sachen daraus lesen,
wenn man weiß, wie.
Habe ich in Statistik gelernt. Und in meiner Bachelorarbeit
musst du möglichst viele Diagramme benutzen. Ist ein bisschen random, dann machst du einmal, zeigst du auch verschiedene Diagramme für verschiedene Situationen und dann hast du deine Bachelorarbeit im Kasten. Du willst ja auch noch ein Bachelor machen. Ich mache noch ein Bachelor auf jeden Fall. Ohne Scheiß, weil ich glaube, es nagt so ein bisschen an dir diesen ... Ja, deine akademische Überlegenheit ist mir im Dorn im Auge auf jeden Fall. Ich denke mir immer so, wäre ich doch nur gern so schlau wie er. Du lässt ja wirklich jeden einzelnen Brief an Bachelor Stephan Tietze adressieren. Du hast wirklich jeden dazu gezwungen, mitgereiht. Manchmal übertreibe ich es mit Dr. Matt Dent. Es ist kompletter Schwachung. In jedem Notizbuch, in jedem Telefonnummernbuch stehst du als Bachelor Stephan Tietze. Es reicht mir auch. Aber im Sinne von Junggeselle meine ich es eigentlich. Ja, ja, Single. Single, ja. Solo. Bachelor. Stefan Solo. Nicht so wie der ... Also ich habe schon noch einen Bachelor, aber ich meine es nicht so. Ich meine es so, wie das wie Solo-Tit sind. Ach ja. Am Ende des Tages ist das hier nur ein Podcast. Und am Ende des Tages machen wir unsere Scherze über die Wahl, aber das entscheidet das Leben. Alter, bald ist es ein Atomkrieg und es gibt alles nicht mehr. Aber angenommen, du guckst in den Himmel und siehst so eine schöne Langstreckenrakete, ich weiss gar nicht, ob das, ich glaube, die würden es in die andere Richtung schießen, aber nur mal hypothetisch. Man geht raus auf den Hof hier, die ganzen Mitarbeiter haben sich in den Arm und es fliegen so zwei Langstreckenraketen über uns Richtung Amerika. Letzten Worte. Schon spannend, oder? Du bist doch jemand, du hast letzte Worte in der Hinterhand. Ja, ich habe letzte Worte in der Hinterhand. Falls jetzt wirklich so dieser Atompilz, und dann muss man sich anscheinend auf dem Boden legen, wo ich mir denke, nope, ich werde den Teufel tun und auf dem Boden legen. Genau, in dem Moment muss man springen. Weißt du, ich habe gelernt, schon an der Ostsee damals, wenn Wellen kommen, springe ich über die Welle. Und auch die Atomwelle. Und auch mit dem Aufzug, wenn der Aufzug runterstürzt, musst du kurz bevor du aufschlägst in die Luft springen und du bist safe. Ja, genau. Wenn eine Atomwürmer kommt, ich werde doch nicht am Boden liegen und meine letzten Worte so in Staub murmeln, werde ich doch nicht machen, ich werde stehen. Was? Noch einen Tweet rauszuhauen, was ist dein letzter Tweet? Tschaui, baui. Macht's gut, ihr Erokesen? Schön war's schön gewesen, ihr Erokesen? Ja, oder so ein Outing oder so. Helene Fischer fand ich rückblickend gar nicht so schlecht. Ciao. Ciao. Ey, aber das ist, ich find's, also so ein kleiner Teil Teil in mir, würde es schon mal gerne miterleben. Klar. So ein Krieg. Würden wir doch alle gern. Ja. Ich glaube, das war auch so die Stimmung vom Ersten Weltkrieg, wo alle gesagt haben, so, oh, jetzt mal ein Krieg. So ein Pferd, so eine Kutsche. Wir brauchen einen Grund. Wir brauchen einen Grund. Einfach einen Grund. Einfach einen Grund, einfach einen Grund, irgendwie irgendwas in Österreich. Lass uns so einen Kaiser... So einen Fenstersturz. Lass uns mal nach Prag fahren. Ja. Das Podcast-Ufer on Tour in Prag und dann schmeißt du irgendeinen Typen aus dem Fenster. Zack, das hat auch gut funktioniert. Das ist der eigentliche Motor der Geschichte, Prag. Prag war immer so ein Teil, so ein kleiner Teil der Geschichte. Stark in Prag. Immer gut. Der Staat in Prag. Ja, lass uns mal so einen neuen Krieg auslesen. Ich glaube, das braucht man langsam, damit alle mal ein bisschen runterkommen. Und da funktioniert auch Humor. Da sind wir doch gebraucht. Der Witz, der die Welt in Brand setzte. Wer zuletzt lacht ... Das könnte die Art-Logo heißen.
Glaubst du, es kommt dazu?
Nö.
War eine richtige Einschätzung?
Ich denke mir auch, die haben sich offen beleidigt, die haben offen gesagt, wir werden uns abschießen.
Die Stakes sind jetzt schon sehr hoch.
Aber es fühlt sich noch sehr weit weg an, der Atomkrieg.
Auch die ganzen Experten sagen, naja, es kommt wahrscheinlich nicht dazu.
Was muss denn passieren?
Beide profitieren ja davon, dass alle Angst haben. Niemand profitiert davon, seine Warnungen ernsthaft zu machen. Der hier, Nordkorea muss sein Volk in Angst und Schrecken halten, Donald Trump auch. Das ist das Dümmste, was sie machen könnten, ist es tatsächlich zu machen. Weil dann ist Kritik, dann ist Stress, Verbündete, dann werden die irgendwie verlieren. Trotzdem sind beide die Stakes des Wortgefechts schon sehr hoch. Die können ja nicht wieder zurückrudern. Nein, die rudern doch seit Jahren. Du, sag mal, die haben doch zweimal die Olympiade gewonnen, so lange wie die rudern. Beow! Den bist du, hast du aber immer von Kilometer weit herkommen sehen. Ach, Herr Rudern sehen, du. Ich glaube, das ist die beste Situation, die die haben können. Ein Staatsführer, der die Angst braucht, wird niemals wirklich was machen.
Weil dann ist Gewissheit, dann sind Fakten, dann ist hier Krieg, dann muss was passieren.
Oder bälle die Hunden, bunzen nicht.
Das ist meine politische Alternative.
Bessessigbrot, das essig. Ja, lecker Brot. Mh, mh, Brot. Und mit dieser weltpolitischen Einschätzung verabschieden und Stefan Tietze und meine Wenigkeit von dieser Folge des Podcast UFO. Merkwürdige Folge, aber die sieben ist immer ein bisschen tricky. Ich wünsche euch alles Gute. Guckt ab und zu mal in den Himmel und so lange keine, auch ganz kurz nochmal eben. Ich dachte die ganze Zeit naiverweise, wenn die halt dann seit, die wissen ja, seit Stunden fliegen diese Dinger genau auf uns zu, schießen wir die einfach ab. Stellt sich raus, extrem schwierig, die abzuschießen. Und wir sind alle eigentlich nur eine grosse Zielschreibe für Kim Jong-un.
Mit diesem Wissen, dass man das nicht verhindern kann, das kommende Übel.
Wünsche ich euch eine schöne Woche. Bis dann.
Wir heben ab.